los tres dedos levantados en señal de
resistencia en mianmar manifestar se
requiere de coraje los que se oponen a
la junta militar lo saben y arriesgan
sus vidas en cada protesta desde el
golpe de estado militar del pasado 1 de
febrero el ejército y la policía han
matado a más de 1200 personas
oficialmente
recurriendo también con frecuencia a la
tortura y la práctica de la tortura
ocurre en todo el territorio nacional a
manos del ejército y la policía pasan
las ciudades en los pueblos contra todo
tipo de personas jóvenes mayores en
diversos grupos étnicos y calles
esta degradación humana se suma a la
creciente crisis económica durante los
10 años de transición democrática de
2011 2021 mianmar se había convertido en
una especie de paraíso para los
inversores explotaciones mineras
transporte industria textil turismo
bancos en total cuenta con más de 130
empresas en todos estos sectores clave
los militares no quieren oír ni hablar
de ayuda humanitaria en varias ocasiones
han destruidos las reservas de arroz o
medicamentos destinados a la población
el resultado me han mar se hunde
lentamente la pobreza tanto es así que
naciones unidas advierte que el nivel de
vida del país corre el riesgo de
retroceder 15 años cuando una de cada
dos personas vivía por debajo del umbral
de la pobreza